[Musique]
c'est un rendez vous incontournable
depuis à 1982 avec l'arrivée de l'été
c'est bien sûr la fête de la musique la
musique et 2019 ne va pas déroger à la
règle pour en parler mélanie poquet
bonsoir on s'arme pour votre coup de
coeur vous nous donner quelques idées de
sorties
il en doute et grégory va falloir faire
un choix la fête de la musique c'est à
travers 120 pays et 2000 villes à
travers le monde
on va pas partir aussi loin mais dans
les yvelines il a largement de quoi
faire alors on débute avec le nord du
département
du côté de saint germain en laye les
festivités débutent dès 16 heures place
du marché neuf
démonstrations initiations de danses
bretonnes à 19h le rock et la variété
française prendront la suite des
animations rossi lieu dans la cour de la
maison des associations sur parvis de
l'église saint germain ou encore la
place préfet erignac à croissy-sur-seine
nous traversent l'atlantique direction
les états unis avec la venue prochaine
de l'amérique de l'équipe américaine de
football à l'occasion de la coupe du
monde le thème était tout trouvé pour la
commune
le public pourra écouter du rock de la
folk de la country et tout ça commence à
18h30 pour skate park alors le principe
de cette fête de la musique c'est bien
sûr de donner l'opportunité aux amateurs
et aux passionnés de s'essayer à
guyancourt on a bien compris ce principe
et oui talents locaux rime avec mois de
juin dans la commune à partir de 18h et
jusqu'à minuit
cinq espaces scéniques vous attendre
quarante groupes vont s'y succéder des
groupes éclectiques le mot d'ordre de la
salle en général une première cette
année toutes les classes de l'école
municipale vous proposeront un concert
itinérant ce sont quelques villes parmi
tant d'autres bien sûr j'aurais pu aussi
souhaité citer voisins le bretonneux
avec sa scène ouverte coignières dont
c'est la toute première fête de la
musique
maurepas où ce sont les terrasses qui
s'anime magny les hameaux qui mêle la
musique à l'art plastique
merci
on vous retrouve dans un instant pour le
7-8 culture avec une page consacrée non
pas la fête de la musique mais elle a
fait de la musique vous allez recevoir
qui en plateau il y aura trois communes
qui seront présentes pour parler de la
programmation les clayes-sous-bois et
ses clés si belle guyancourt et magny
les hameaux et s'étant trouvées bien sûr
après ce journal